etymology etymology explores the history
and development of individual words the
origins of a languages lexical items it
asks a question you're likely familiar
with that question is where did this
word come from you've probably
encountered etymologies when someone
explained the meaning of a word or when
you sought out the origin of a word for
yourself as a linguistic study this
question is approached methodically so
it requires that we understand the
methods that we'll use to discover word
origins specifically etymology requires
an understanding of the parts of words
their pronunciation and grammar
components so you'll need some
understanding of phonology and
morphology etymology is also a
diachronic process what this means is
that etymology is a function of the
languages change over time so etymology
will make more sense if you if you're
already versed in the fundamentals of
historical linguistics if you are aware
of key concepts like cognates and
borrowings reconstruction of proto
languages and discussions about what is
a language and what is a dialect we can
start to build etymologies for the
etymology of a particular word we'll
need to know about language change over
time in general and the history of
change in a particular language that
we're analyzing we'll also need to know
the history of borrowing borrowed words
are called loan words or loans borrowing
into that particular language and in
turn the historical changes that those
source languages that were the source of
the borrowings underwent notice that
words are often borrowed or inherited
from non-standard forms of a language
and that adds to the complexity
take for instance medieval Norman French
borrowings into middle English like the
word chief which is not the same as the
modern French word chef or the
interesting case of dialect mixing which
accounts for the word pear shirt and
skirt in modern English
so with those complexities in mind let's
discuss how we trace the path of a word
as it's sound in its form change as much
as is possible we rely on historical
attestation here we expect our etymology
to account for the
evidence that is the word that we're
tracing as it was actually used
throughout its history for example the
modern English word Queen goes back to
an earlier Quanah in Middle English this
word is attested in Chaucer Quay 9 turn
derives from Old English Queen attested
in Beowulf here we can say that the
etymon or source word of Queen is the
Old English Queen but we aren't
restricted by the attested evidence
there are two ways to trace a more
distant origin first we might discover
that a word was influenced by or
borrowed from another dialect or another
language like the English word chief
which was barred from French in this
case our etymology can continue in that
source language second we can increase
our time depth by comparing related
languages and engaging in the process of
historical reconstructions a clever
intellectual development I introduced in
the lesson on historical linguistics
therefore as much as possible our
etymology will take into account the
history of borrowing it influenced and
will terminate at the earliest
reconstructed form of a word not the
earliest attested form for example the
old English word Queen can be compared
to other early Germanic words like the
Gothic quince or the Old Norse fan
allowing us to reconstruct the
proto-germanic ancestral form as Queen
is when we compare the proto-germanic
word to cognates in other non dramatic
indo-european languages like the ancient
Greek word Renee and the sanskrit na we
can begin to reconstruct a
proto-indo-european root like goon or
Guin
will then see that Grimm's law applies
to all Germanic languages which changed
voiceless stops to fricatives and voice
stops to voiceless stops giving us a
root Quinn beginning with the voiceless
sound K rather than the voice G orga you
know when I said that Grimm's law
applies to all Germanic languages that
doesn't mean that it still impacts
modern languages but like all sound laws
it effected words at one point in
history in this case in proto-germanic
so let's review what we've done here we
found the earliest attested form of
Queen in English compared it to
words in related Germanic languages to
trace the word to a reconstructed
proto-germanic word and compared
proto-germanic to related indo-european
languages to trace the word even further
back to a reconstructed proto
indo-european root word along the way we
paid attention to sound changes notice
that you'll find an asterisk next to
reconstructed forms and also notice how
the derivational pass is represented
visually Grannis becomes quayne which
becomes Quanah or Quanah comes from
Gwaine which comes from Quinn is it's
also crucial to understand morphology to
know what kind of word you're dealing
with especially key here is word
formation the way affixes are added to
roots to form new words which is
derivation or how words are compounded
to form new words which is compounding
inflectional morphemes are certainly
considered but they're really part of
the grammar or structure of a language
while etymology often focuses on content
words or content morphemes an example of
why morphology matters when doing
etymology when we trace the history of
Queen
we arrived at a proto-germanic word
Queen is which has an inflectional
suffix is attached to the root now in a
separate instance you might be doing the
etymology of say the word illogical that
root that word has a root log and three
derivational affixes a suffix pick a
suffix full and a prefix in which
assimilated too ill to do justice to the
etymology of these words you'll need to
understand and know the derivation of
these morphemes in the next video I'll
talk about the role of semantics
particularly meaning change in etymology
and I'll also touch on basic conventions
followed when presenting in etymology
hope this has been helpful and see you
then